je suis donc marraine de la montheysanne
et quand les organisateurs de ce thé
dicks m'ont dit que c'était à ce titre
qu'ils avaient pensé à m'inviter il a
fallu que je réfléchisse à une façon de
vous parler de cet engagement de devenir
puisque c'est le thème du jour et ça n'a
pas été très compliqué à trouver puis je
trouve finalement plus cette soirée
avance et plus je pense que la physique
du don de soi pour reprendre mon titre
que vous avez peut-être comprendre au
fil de dix minutes n'est pas très loin
de la physique du tedx la montheysanne
justement j'y étais il ya pas si
longtemps c'était le 25 août dernier la
huitième édition de cet événement c'est
vraiment pour moi un événement génial
chaque fois j'en reviens bouleversé
galvanisé plein d'espoir dans l'humain
et je peux vous dire que quand on
présente le téléjournal ça peut servir
une petite réserve de d'espoir dans
l'humain alors la montheysanne pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas peut-être en deux
mots c'est donc une course qui a lieu
tous les mois d'août à monthey d'où son
nom et qui a cette particularité qui a
si radicale mais qui a fait aussi sa
réputation c'est que ce ne sont que des
femmes qui courent
la plupart du temps aux roses comme vous
le voyez et ces femmes courent ou
marchent pour certaines pour financer la
recherche et l'aide au quotidien des
personnes malades du cancer du sein en
particulier les plus largement du cancer
et donc
ça fait depuis le début que givet la
première année nous étions 560
je crois en 2012 cette année nous étions
2100 à courir sans parler de tous ceux
qui qui assure la logistique les hommes
mettent notamment qui sont là quand même
très présent souvent sur cet événement
et puis j'ai beaucoup réfléchi en fait à
pourquoi en fait finalement à quoi ça
sert voilà à quoi ça sert de courir pour
une cause ce que finalement ce serait
pas plus simple un peu moins exigeants
peut-être de ne pas payer le montant du
dos à le verser au fonds pour aller au
bout du raisonnement et puis rester chez
soi dans son canapé ou éventuellement
venir boire un verre mais en tout cas
pas courir 5 km 10 km finalement à quoi
ça sert moi je suis convaincu que ça a
un sens metz j'ai quand même mis un
moment à élaborer ma petite théorie
là-dessus pour vous expliquer ce que
j'en pense je vais faire un petit retour
en arrière
un peu moins de trois ans en arrière
pour être précise le 17 octobre 2016
c'est un jour important dans ma vie ma
vie je peux le dire un peu basculer ce
jour là ou plutôt cette nuit là puisque
j'ai été réveillé par un grand bruit
mon mari s'était effondré dans la salle
de bain victime d'un malaise
li à une embolie pulmonaire massive je
vous la fait courte cette semaine
d'hôpital sans intensif opération
transfert à zurich et finalement cette
semaine plus tard il est décédé
il avait 48 ans nous enfants n'avaient à
l'époque 4 et 11
alors je vous raconte pas ça simplement
pour le plaisir de vous d'évoquer ma vie
personnelle ici mais ce que j'aime ce
dont j'aimerais parler ce soir c'est de
ce qui s'est passé pendant ces sept
semaines autour de nous ça a commencé
par quelque chose de très simple c'est
simplement j'ai alerté le réseau des
copines nous avons un groupe avec mes
mamans copines comme on dit c'est à dire
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent ça on commence par les
apéros le jogging les sorties le week
end shopping finalement les hommes
trouvent ça sympa donc ils viennent
aussi on fait des barbecues en famille
et finalement ils se créent comme ça un
groupe de gens qui sont
des amis dont on pense qu'ils sont
précieux mais qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'occasion d'éprouver si je puis dire et
donc j'envoie un message le jour même de
l'hospitalisation de mon mari à mes amis
pour les informer de ce qui se passe et
là il se passe quelque chose c'est que
l'une d'entre elles créent un autre
groupe de messagerie dans lequel ne
m'intègre pas dont elle ne me parle pas
et où toutes les autres sont et à partir
de là elles ont été avec leur famille le
soutien logistique
pendant ces sept semaines sur lequel
rien n'aurait pu se passer c'est à dire
que je disais je dois partir demain à
zurich devant mon mari dans les dix
minutes j'avais un message qui me disait
tu peux poser tes enfants là tu peux
aller les chercher là je les récupère et
accessoirement avec une balise de linge
propre et tout ça pendant cette semaine
alors qu'elles sont en tout cas aussi
occupé que moi elles ont toutes des
enfants une vie bref elles ont de quoi
faire déjà et si je vous parle de ça
c'est que bien sûr ça et des avantages
très concret ça a permis à mes enfants
de continuer leur vie à peu près
normalement moi ça m'a permis de me
consacrer quand même à des moments
importants dans la mienne
et puis elle était là aussi d'ailleurs
pour me ramasser à la petite cuillère
parfois quand j'entraîne l'hôpital mais
surtout si j'en parle c'est parce que
j'ai été bouleversée et est aussi portée
par le réaliser en fait ce que
représentait cet investissement cet
effort silencieux qu'elle faisait de
porter en plus de leur vie la mienne
mais de s'occuper de mes enfants de
prendre en charge mon chagrin
c'était quelque chose de très fort de
n'être conscient et ça m'a vraiment
littéralement porté ça m'a donné de la
force
ce qui m'amène un peu au coeur de ce que
je voulais vous dire ce soir c'est à
dire que pour moi il y a une énergie
l'effort génère une énergie et que cette
énergie elle elle est une force
incroyable si on si on utilise à bon
escient
je crois que la solidarité n'est pas un
état je crois qu'on n'est pas solidaire
on agit solidaire c'est le don de soi
justement et je pense que quelqu'un qui
donne de lui-même pour pour une autre
personne pour une cause et bien génère
une énergie qui sans doute lui profite
un peu aussi il ya bien une satisfaction
c'est clair et tant mieux
mais surtout il génère une énorme force
qui peut être utile je reviens la
montheysanne l'année suivante le décès
de mon mari j étais comme chaque année
au même endroit et c'était très
particulier parce que j'ai dû comme
chaque année faire mon petit discours de
la marraine est devant moi il y avait
les mêmes personnes enfin plus ou moins
le même nuage de tee shirt rose il y
avait les mêmes jeté sur la même estrade
le même micro et pourtant tout avait
changé et en fait je vous parle de ce
moment parce que c'est à ce moment-là
précis que j'ai pris conscience de ce
que je viens de vous expliquer c'est à
dire que j'ai ressenti la réalité de
cette force de cette énergie générée par
tous ces gens qui avaient fait l'effort
de venir par toutes ces femmes qui
avaient fait l'effort de s'entraîner de
venir courir pour cette cause et j'ai eu
la conviction que oui il se passait
quelque chose qui pouvait servir à ceux
qui de leur côté se battait contre la
maladie ou entouraient quelqu'un qui se
bat contre la maladie
je faisais allusion tout à l'heure au
fait que parfois dans mon métier c'est
compliqué garder espoir en l'humanité
c'est vrai que quand on est présentateur
du téléjournal que tous les jours on
voit un peu les malheurs du monde
c'est parfois compliqué de garder
confiance et pourtant je suis quelqu'un
de plutôt optimiste malgré les
catastrophes malgré la laideur humaine
parfois l'injustice de la vie''
malgré la grande catastrophe climatique
dont il est beaucoup question en ce
moment je pense qu'il y a de l'espoir
une grande partie de cet espoir pour moi
est liée à cette énergie là alors bien
sûr les mouvements de foule collectif
s'est pas toujours positif ça j'en suis
consciente également bien sûr
l'actualité l'histoire nous nous le dit
il suffit parfois d'un homme une femme
un peu charismatique du une idée folle
voire d'un buzz aujourd'hui pour générer
aussi des mouvements comme ça qu'ils
peuvent être dangereux
voir inappropriée mais c'est pas de ça
que je veux parler c'est vraiment de ces
mouvements qui génère une énergie
positive j'ai envie de dire je vais
prendre deux exemples qui vont forcément
vous parlez lançait c'est je vais mettre
le side suivant linselles la grève des
femmes
oui lancé la grève des femmes et plus
généralement ce qui s'est passé dans le
sillage du mouvement mis tous la parole
libérée des femmes et puis en suisse ce
jour incroyable cette vague violette que
vous avez vu déferler sur des villes
suisses cette mobilisation inédite des
femmes alors bien sûr il ya eu la
récupération et bien sûr une partie de
cette énergie générée par cet élan c'est
sans doute un peu perdu dans la canicule
de l'été mais moi je suis convaincu
qu'il s'est passé ce jour là quelque
chose de particulier quelque chose
d'unique et qu'il ya au coeur de ce
mouvement un vrai élan qui reprend ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure un
élan qui est une force je pense pour de
nombreuses femmes aujourd'hui qu'ils
n'osaient pas et qui peut être aux ronds
ou osent parler revendiquer voire
simplement être elle même
l'autre exemple que je voulais évoquer
c'est celui de la grève du climat un
autre exemple de ces derniers temps et
dieu sait qu'il est question de cette
question c'est qu'il est question de ce
thème récemment alors là aussi je ne
suis pas totalement naïve
j'ai moi même une ado à la maison qui
était très contente de sacrifier trois
demi journées d'école pour aller avec
ses pancartes ses copines en ville mais
qui est aussi contente d'avoir le
dernier téléphone à la mode et les
habits pas chers fabriqués en chine au
bangladesh
donc ça j'en suis consciente et et c'est
pas pour autant que je vais je vais
lâcher le travail éducatif
ceci dit je pense que l'essentiel est
ailleurs je pense là aussi qu'il y à un
mouvement fondamentale qui qui s'est
créée
et qui grâce aussi parce que parfois la
médiatisation a du bon grâce aussi
peut-être à la médiatisation peut
générer quelque chose de mondial et
peut-être fait cette force qui manque
aujourd'hui pour faire bouger les choses
vraiment il ya une autre chose qui me
donne de l'espoir à titre professionnel
c'est que ma rédaction qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas la seule la rédaction de
l'actualité de la rts est entré dans une
logique un peu différente
d'autres médias le font c'est un
mouvement qui est venu de scandinavie
qui est entre guillemets revendiqué
aujourd'hui par plusieurs rédactions on
appelle ça le journalisme constructif et
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est qu'on
s'est rendu compte que peut-être de
faire simplement le catalogue des
misères du monde ce n'était pas
suffisant
c'était peut-être même inutiles et
qu'ils avaient peut-être autre chose à
faire en tant que média de service
public a fortiori et que notre travail
c'était peut-être non seulement
d'expliquer mais aussi parfois de
proposer des solutions d'aller les
chercher ailleurs là où elles existent
de faire état des idées que certaines
personnes ont pour changer les choses
bref de pagnes pas de regarder le monde
avec des lunettes roses mais justement
de contribuer un peu un élan justement
toujours tels que je viens de vous le
décrire pour en revenir au thème de
cette soirée de venir
ce que j'aimerais dire c'est que je suis
personnellement pas pas certaine qu'on
arrivera à sauver la planète à revenir à
inverser le mouvement destruction que
l'humain a entamé par ce que je vois
comme tout le monde ce qui se passe le
climat qui change les les glaciers qui
fondent
je vois aussi l'inertie cette coupe
cette difficulté qu'on a tous et tout a
changé fondamentalement nos
comportements suffisamment vite pour que
on corrige le tir et puis surtout
peut-être je pense qu'on peut avoir un
peu d'humilité comme humain à l'échelle
de l'univers jeu c'est pas exclu quand
même que l'épisode de la fin de l'être
humain soit déjà en train de s'écrire
mais pour autant comme à l'échelle d'une
vie humaine est ce que le fait qu'on
connaisse la fin justifie qu'on
abandonne le chemin parce que c'est
quand même finalement ça le plus
intéressant dans la vie c'est le chemin
et la vertu pour moi de ce qui se passe
avec ses ses élans dont je parlais c'est
qu'elle ramène l'humain à l'essentiel et
en fait ce que j'aimerais dire ce soir
c'est que peut-être que l'humain ne
pourra pas sauver la planète mais
peut-être qu'il peut encore essayer de
sauver son humanité
merci
[Applaudissements]